here is the list of dinner DNT your
written consent millions important
meatball this is the ingredient if
orders for Bethany to kina and this is
for the callback teratoma so what is the
idea well you just have to move please
chop ground everything make little balls
if you make that one smaller than taking
faster and then what I was thinking is
that so we create cook the meatballs 2
vanilla stuff gathered and the same is
true for enablebetting tongue while we
can cook you can make the capacity to
Tina knell for NIU is the Baker yeah
our full effect they were done reading
okay Brody sighs up yep let's go oh you
baby three groups suspect okay chipola
occasional cut these pretty small too
since they're going to be inside it's
not like they're gonna be fried so that
you'd be pretty good shop for you all
right we're we're not going to cook
these separately are we we're not put it
inside so they need to be hanging yeah
you would think I'm your man she knocked
open then you take the SATs each are you
want to take the skin off collector and
then you can use some sausage
intercepting yes you want choppa I got
it that's real lovable very very
horrible yes very small because then
you're going to mix everything together
and then watch the same model and write
thank yous yes you chop it and you put
it in there so the traditional convexity
karna but also harder in fact a chateau
anymore but I thought weekly make a
version that's a little bit lighter and
so lets you try without this opens I
don't forget to add salad and then you
will love cookie lo the pan heat you
have different options you can I would
avoid to shine yeah trying so what you
can tell if he will make us a drink
chipola and I know a lot of chipola
making a sofrito and then take you there
yeah okay man and look that like this or
if you want out also la pasarela Maduro
it would better so let's make some space
everything together and then I put the
weight but you can do it how cute
hahahaha you know this one works better
yeah this is the best two great [ __ ]
job this far it's going to come out to
them even see a different consistency
longer more fluffy oh yeah it's really
good then you wanna mix everything
together make little bowls and then you
cook them and repent locate with a
little bit of all your dough down so
wash the zucchini you starting something
that's fine but it's faster if you use
the greater and there is no naka machi
much thinner then you can use them
directly art or whenever to cook them
with some some random to add the little
taste so you can mix a freak though with
I go and your favorite spit chip we
don't devices and also in this way
they're going to read some of the water
otherwise you think i'm out like
then you let them cool you mix them with
the rest of the ingredients make little
balls and then you cook them yes 400 400
yes and this is the little we're on vaca
piana the coastal past Chiana stagger to
jon dolezar Keenan see it's on it on
your diva so I find a little bit more
tasty but usually i detain longer
because it has been in the camera like
the best quality problem so you want to
drain it it's okay it's not a big deal
if you are these
don't use a metal utensils tulip Adela
I'm candidature otherwise it will be
scratched forever and there will be a
massager so right now we're making this
mix into tiny little balls and then
we're going to cover them together has
cuddle you make sure it's on the right
yeah when we try them
lens your follower perfidor ok so we are
eating our whole pack them call me
salata and we will use the typical and
most basic dressing which is 0 from that
chick about Sumiko ticket hey you suck
in the salad so I hope you will like it
and if you are looking color is the
typical dressing like one spoon of
regular resting is another in something
like 70 calories fill out pretty good
very good
you